what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch today spider-man no way
home cast full trailer 2 reaction we
weren't sure if that was fake or not
that was like 30 seconds but now it's
the full thing so it's real but before
we jump into this john put 30 seconds on
the clock because you're gonna have a
gift here all this will be yours oh boy
we got a funko unboxing to do now all
the folks said was they're sending over
something from their fun covers strategy
game series you play as characters from
some of your favorite pop culture
fandoms going head-to-head over four
different game styles i don't want to
give this to you oh dude oh that's a and
that's an exclusive one to this game
only so we will fight
okay over that
thanos they got all kinds of characters
but let's see who else they sent us to
play with i've already opened the box
shop look at that oh my god this is so
much cooler than the last one
full marvel set they they know us the
shills over here they know we like oh
wow thanks i'm glad i get to have all
these for myself now i think everything
enjoy and if you want some for yourself
check the link in the description box
and pink comments now let's hop into the
video that's what i say oh now let's hop
into the video you do it so much better
[Music]
what up guys
uh this is our first day on the
spider-man no way home press tour
we're about to watch the new trailer
which comes out soon
that's pretty exciting interesting
all right we're ready yeah let's go i'm
quite nervous actually
oh
were you really in times square where am
i like yeah
we were on that bridge
you know how difficult that bridge was
to land
oh
crazy in that one
i love this one it's gonna be so sick
people
what's your name again
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's christmas oh you're flying yeah i
heard it first darn this hmm never had
could never look at what do you mean
yeah because it's always a summer movie
it's always come out in june right right
nice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
nipple chills watching them
i know you can feel just how
that's hard how much like familial
history is there
[Music]
oh
that was so adorbs
where's the this is all my fault i can't
save everyone yes you can
whoa wait a minute what
hold on a second i'm sorry to interrupt
this reaction i gotta play this back
what does he say
he said where's the yeah what's he
alluding to i don't know it's like he
was expecting something to be in there
and then he like caught himself uh-huh
there's the other spider-man
it seemed like he was he was questioning
there's supposed to be something in this
trailer he maybe thought something was
going to be in this trailer where's the
sony brazil shot this trailer is moving
by at such a whiplash pace it's kind of
odd to me that he would be anticipating
something and i've pretty much only
looked at tom holland this whole time
i haven't really been looking at the
other two i keep having to jump back and
forth because the trailer keeps sucking
me in i mean i've been mainly just
married to their faces this entire time
and now you really see the chemistry
between the real-life couple of zendaya
and tom holland here in this video by
the way all right let's continue it but
that would set out to be oh yeah i don't
know what that was let some slip what
the hell was that about yes you can you
can say that
bro do it my god
oh wow
oh oh my god
people are going to go crazy when they
see that bit oh my goodness what's
happening
it's starting to come through
oh my goodness people are not ready
honestly like it's i got scared i know
you guys are alive
high stakes literally well guys that was
the trailer for spider-man nowhere home
it comes out
really soon yeah like it comes out in a
few days what comes up tomorrow
it comes out tomorrow so this will
probably come out after that
yeah can release this first yeah
first look
it's just us
all right anyway that was fun yeah that
was fine i'll see you guys soon
oh [ __ ]
dude oh you said another thing i gotta
rewind it back to really quick when dr
strange popped up hold on he's expecting
i think look toby and andrew are
definitely in that the statue of liberty
sequence all right he says certain words
and he seems like he's about to let [ __ ]
slip classic tom hall in fashion oh my
goodness what's happening
they're starting to come through
but i can't stop them
oh my goodness people are
who he's behaving yeah
so focused he almost called something
out he's like that's that's what is that
i don't say what he's about to say oh
how fascinating i mean yeah because i
have to imagine this isn't the first
footage or finished footage they've seen
so they gotta know you know what some of
these shots look like completed
oh yeah i wouldn't be surprised actually
if at least tom holland seen the movie
yeah absolutely or like an early version
of it to say the least i mean you know
maybe they don't let him do that anymore
i have no idea especially him yeah yeah
but it's just so funny to watch it back
before and not be sure if they're really
reacting to something especially with
jacob battle on you're like what's he
can't tell if he's like faking it yeah
this is what we go through yeah
people in the comments they're like oh
fake
correction
but then you have the footage playing
you're like oh [ __ ] that's sincere
yeah it's real they were really watching
something it could just be two that
they've seen some of this before so like
yeah there there's a difference in
seeing something that you've never been
exposed to but yeah this played a lot
more naturally it definitely felt like
they were being shown this trailer for
the first time i just felt so happy for
them i mean you got to imagine how it is
on their end like for us who have been
so heavily anticipating at us along with
so many of you the amount of like
coverage around this one film now that
they're finally getting a chance to show
more footage and be able to talk about
it during press just a little bit more
when the film finally comes out this
must be like an incredibly joyous
celebration of a moment to be watching
this trailer and then like watching them
was like oh [ __ ] this is this is like a
great reaction video right here i really
i really i was feeling so happy like wow
what must whatever
i'm feeling they must be feeling that
like a million times more like god damn
that's yeah
the pride they must be feeling alone
just being involved with this and having
it finally reach the world has got to be
overwhelming that was beautiful i
actually quite enjoyed that a lot i i
love that that's my favorite youtube
videos i've seen all year let's get them
on let's get them a channel let's get
them reacting to all the new trailers
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that
notification bell we got more spiderman
no way home stuff to talk about until
the movie comes out and maybe they might
drop another trailer in the meantime
eddie here guys leave your thoughts down
below we will catch you guys soon and
thank you to funko gaming why'd you cut
me off i know that
[Music]
you